[Music]
when we first announced that we were
going to be bringing coffee to market
that didn't involve a coffee bean we
thought that we might receive a lot of
pushback from the industry and in fact
it's been the complete opposite
everyone seems very encouraged that
there is now an alternative to
conventional coffee
[Music]
three years ago when we started this
company we did a lot of research on
coffee and we found out that coffee is
actually in trouble
where coffee is being grown today is
being affected by climate change and so
coffee farmers are going to have to move
their crops to higher elevations and the
places that they're moving their crops
are some of the last wild places on
earth and so really coffee is going to
lead to massive deforestation over the
next 30 years so what we hope to do is
as demand increases we hope to offload
that demand
and not require continued deforestation
to supply the global need for coffee
etobo makes a better tasting coffee
that's actually better for the planet
to reinvent coffee we decided to
understand exactly what's in the cup of
coffee we identified that there's
actually 28 compounds that are
absolutely necessary to replicate the
coffee experience
so to make coffee without the coffee
bean you actually have to find the
coffee bean equivalent
our product is made with upcycled
ingredients from u.s farmers and it's
all plant-based material
autumnal coffee is different than
conventional coffee mostly because of
our sustainability for tomo coffee the
primary ingredient is date seeds and
right now the daisies are just being
thrown away by the farmers but there's
enough date seeds in the world to make
billions of cups of coffee every single
day
when people ask us is this really coffee
we say absolutely it's coffee
coffee for us is a ritual it's an
experience and as a result you want the
taste the aroma the smell but you also
want the caffeine and our coffee
delivers the exact same experience and
the exact same result
in the same format as coffee
so our product lineup starts with cold
brew in a can then we will soon be
releasing our instant coffee for hot and
grounds we always generate grounds here
but one day we put the hot coffee in the
refrigerator we had it the next day as a
cold brew and we said wow this is
amazing so we really decided that
sharing our new invention with the world
in a cold brew was the most controlled
and perfect way of showing our invention
we think every coffee drinker out there
wants to have the opportunity to do
something better for the planet each day
and as long as we make the coffee taste
exactly like coffee
then really we think that consumers now
have a better choice without giving up
any experience